Guten Morgen Lino. Guten Morgen Tim.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim. Sag mal, ist das hier eigentlich Logbuch Netzpolitik? Ich ich muss unbedingt wissen, ob das Netzpolitik ist. Die Frage ist für mich wichtig.
Ja, es ist in der Tat Lokbuch-Netzpolitik die hundertneunte Ausgabe. Wir sind dann doch äh bei Sinnen. Ja. Ja.
Ja. Wir sind ja nicht auf den Kopf gefallen.
Denken noch ganz klar, das wäre ja auch sonst ein bisschen blöd, nicht dass wir dann so mitten in der Sendung ausgewechselt werden.
Ja oder uns nicht mehr dran erinnern können.
Was am Anfang war. Mal gucken, wie es aussieht. Ja, ja. Äh ist äh was Wichtiges passiert,
Nichts, wa? Sicher?
Nein. Ja, wir haben jetzt noch einen zweiten Spion gehabt,
aber äh wenn es dabei bleibt, was wir jetzt wissen, sind die durch diese mutmaßliche Spionage gewonnenen Informationen lächerlich. Versichert uns, Herr Messia,
während äh Herr Schäuble aber sagt, das ist ja sowas von blöd von den USA, dass sie uns einen Spion schicken oder sogar zwei, wo sie doch die Informationen bekommen können, wenn sie einfach nur fragen. Ist ja sowas von blöd.
Sowas von blöd. Also der erste war äh Doktor Netzpolitik berichtete äh der Herr aus der Poststelle, der irgendwie äh Dokumente kopiert hat für günstig Geld.
Den sie jetzt irgendwie inzwischen in den Medien äh runtergespielt haben zu ich glaube so hundert Prozent Schwerbehinderung oder so, ne? Also der war ja offensichtlich geistig und körperlich vollständig ungeeignet äh beim Nachrichtendienst zu arbeiten.
Ja, geht das eigentlich auch für alle anderen, die da arbeiten? Bei der weiteren Überprüfung.
Da gibt's immer so Randartikel, wo sie sagen, so ja und ähm.
Ist uns gar nicht aufgefallen.
Arm und äh im Kopf waren ja auch äh verrückt. Und so fasst sich wieder jemals in in diese Position gekommen.
Ja, der hat immer, der hat immer so einen Aluhut getragen und irgendwie von von Außerirdischen gesprochen.
Ja. Na gut, aber ich meine, wir sind trotzdem vollständig äh vollsten Vertrauens, dass die äh Behörden doch äh immer nur die schönsten und Besten einstellen, nicht wahr?
Auf jeden Fall, das sehen wir ja auch bei Herrn Missi und Herrn Schäuble.
Aber es gab jetzt noch zwei.
Nimm,
einem zweiten Jahr und äh jetzt habe ich, ich glaube, der saß im Bundesverteidigungsministerium und ähm derjenige, der den, da gab's da irgendwie eine Zwischenmeldung, deshalb nicht mehr ganz verfolgt, der hat derjenige, der den koordinieren sollte, war der erste Spion,
aber den haben sie irgendwie anders gefunden und jetzt äh dann haben sie als Reaktion.
Wie der erste sollte den zweiten koordinieren. Nach soweit war er dann schon aufgestiegen. Hat aber trotzdem sich nochmal per E-Mail an die russische Botschaft gewandelt, ob da nicht auch noch irgendwie mitspielen kann.
Na ja, wenn du erstmal so ein Team hast.
Ah, ja, ich meine, das ist halt irgendwie so ein Start-Up muss natürlich auch äh sich äh neue Märkte suchen. Da ist was dran.
Die Investoren kommen und fragen. Also, jetzt mal Spaß beiseite. Was hat denn dieser zweite Spion so äh spioniert haben?
Ja, das äh also lächerliche Sachen im Verteidigungsministerium.
Wo war denn der überhaupt? Ja, aber wo, also ich meine, was saß er da in in der in der Lobby oder war da der Assistent von irgendjemanden oder.
Na ja, die Sache ist doch ähm man weiß es nicht. Es wird uns ja auch nicht gesagt. Also es wird halt nur immer darauf hingewiesen, dass es alles lächerlich war,
und äh dass man die Information ja auch hätte bekommen können, wenn man fragt.
Also es hätte sich sozusagen um handelsübliche Spionage gehandelt. Also wie man sie im jeden Supermarkt.
Also der deshbie ist es war eben einer im Verteidigungsministerium, aber da habe ich jetzt auch nicht mehr ähm,
nicht mehr weiter nachgeschaut, weil ich mich dann natürlich vollständig auf die äh Beschwichtigungslinie der Regierung eingeschwungen habe.
Hm.
Ne? Jetzt haben wir ja alle. Wenn wir innerhalb von einer Woche zwei Spione finden, dann haben wir ja alle.
Also wir haben sozusagen, hast du, ich verstehe, es gibt nur zwei Spione und zwar einen schwarzen und einen weißen.
Und und dann hat der äh äh Steinmeier ja noch gesagt, ähm,
auch in die in diesem Zusammenhang. Also viel spannender finde ich da die Politikerzitate, ne. Also was die Spione jetzt da gemacht haben und wo die waren, die waren natürlich alle immer in ganz lächerlichen Positionen und haben äh lächerliche Informationen weitergegeben, ne, das waren ja alles irgendwie geistig verwirrte Einzeltäter. Klar.
Ne, äh in so einem Team von hundert Leuten einer geistig verwirrt. Ähm,
der ähm Steinmeier,
Sagte dann ja, weil so unsere Kooperation mit den USA ähm,
wollen wir ja nicht aufgeben. Es wäre eine Illusion, zu glauben, dass die Entschärfung
dass eine Entschärfung der Konflikte, wie auch die Erarbeitung politischer Lösungen ohne enge Zusammenarbeit mit den USA gelingen könne, denn unsere Partnerschaft mit den USA ist,
ohne Alternative.
Alternativlos, habe ich das schon mal irgendwo gehört.
Genau,
Also diese Reaktion fand ich sehr schön, aber es gab ja dann doch eine, denn ähm man hat ja dann sich schriftlich an äh die US-Botschaft gewendet, wenn ich das richtig äh rekonstruiere. Und,
sie gebeten den CIA-Chefkoordinator ähm auszuweisen,
Ja, also du kennst das, ne, wenn du sonst wenn wenn der Skandal so richtig vor sich hin, dann muss jemand den Hut nehmen, ne? Dann muss irgendwo ein Bauernopfer fallen
und äh die US, die Bundesregierung hat also dann sich jemanden ausgesucht und das war ähm,
der CIA-Vertreter der in der amerikanischen Botschaft in Berlin. Und dann haben sie ihm.
Finde ich ja schon mal ganz interessant, dass ihr den überhaupt kennen.
Der der ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ich glaube sein Name kam im im Rahmen dessen raus. Also ähm aber,
Interessanterweise diese beiden Spione, die wurden natürlich von Österreich aus koordiniert,
Du bist ja nicht so blöd und setzt in dem Land den Geheimdienstkoordinator ein. Da lässt du ja lieber jemanden aus äh aus Österreich rüber, ja, sonst könnte ja, wenn der auffliegt,
könnte der ja des Landes verwiesen wären, wäre ja blödsinnig, ne. So, also äh koordinierst du das natürlich lieber aus dem Ausland
und ähm dann haben sie also einen Brief geschrieben, äh wo sie sagten, sie würden sich also jetzt, sie würden das schätzen, äh wenn diese Person denn dann bitte ähm das Land verlassen würde.
Ähm es.
Was natürlich jetzt sagen wir mal auf diplomatischer Ebene schon ein, wie sagt man, Affront ist, also ein.
Na ja, sie haben nicht den den Schritt äh sie sind nicht diesen diplomatischen Schritt gegangen, weil du kannst ähm jemanden auch zur Persona Non-Krater,
erklären. Das wäre also der tatsächliche harsche Ton. Das haben sie nicht gemacht.
Ja gut, aber dann würde es ja gegen die Person selbst gehen und die Person selbst war ja an der Stelle eigentlich eher egal. Also ich meine, es war sein,
Am Amt oder die, die ihm zugewiesene Rolle an der Stelle, die dort quasi thematisiert wird und nicht so sehr die Person selbst. Das hätte jetzt irgendjemand sein können.
Ähm da bin ich mir nicht so also ich,
glaube nicht, dass der als Chef äh Koordinator CIA seinen Diplomatenstatus in Deutschland bekommen hat. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass der irgendeine andere offizielle äh einen, einen anderen offiziellen Titel hatte, aber da muss ich leider sagen, dass ich das nicht genau weiß.
Hm, ja, also es äh ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen schockierend, dass wir über interne, geheimdienstliche Vorgänge nicht im Detail informiert sind. Aber sowas passiert halt auch im besten Podcast.
Vor allem ist das ja alles lächerlich. Der Mann hat dann ähm auch entsprechend, weil ja nur darauf hingewiesen wurde, dass man sich freuen würde, wenn er dann irgendwann gehen würde,
hat er sich dann auch Zeit gelassen. Es gab dann noch äh die Meldung, dass der dass er das ignorieren würde, aber äh es
äh heute gegangen, heute ist der siebzehnte siebte und das heißt, dass er irgendwie sich acht Tage Zeit gelassen hat, für jemanden, der sein Lebensmittelpunkt äh wieder zurück in ein anderes Land verlegt, denke ich, ist das immer noch eine relativ flotte Zeit.
Ja. Gibt's irgendwelche Erkenntnisse da drüber, wie lange der hier war? Nee, ne.
Ähm die gibt es sicherlich auch, aber auch da ähm habe ich hier vor der Sendung gesagt, dass ich bei einigen Themen nicht ganz so tief bin, weil ich den Schwerpunkt gerne woanders setzen würde.
Ja, wir können ja, wir können ja äh unsere Mitarbeiter in der amerikanischen Botschaft mal fragen, ob sie uns das passende Fax kopieren können. Hm, oh, das hätte ich jetzt nicht sagen sollen, oder?
So, nee, es gibt auf jeden, also in den Artikeln, die mir als Quelle, die in äh steht erstmal nicht drin, wie lange ähm er da war.
Na ja, macht ja nichts.
Nochmal schauen. Auf jeden Fall, nee, Quatsch. Jetzt doch, das fällt mir wieder ein. Der hat nämlich der Typ, den sie jetzt ausgewiesen haben,
ist erst seit ein oder zwei Jahren da im Dienst,
und diese Kooperation mit dem äh mit dem BND-Mitarbeiter äh ist,
Vor seiner Amtszeit gewesen. Das heißt, der Typ, den sie jetzt ausweisen, äh ist erst seit Kurzem da. Zu die Kooperation fing nämlich zweitausendzwölf an.
Und das war sogar noch ein anderer Botschafter, nämlich äh Murphy,
Und jetzt ist es ja Amazon, der ist aber erst seit letztem Jahr da,
und der Typ, den sie jetzt ausweisen, würde ich jetzt vermuten, ist wahrscheinlich auch mit Amazon gekommen und äh entsprechend noch nicht lange im Amt.
Na ja gut und äh das mit dem Lebensmittelpunkt auch nicht ganz so schlimm.
Ja, ich meine, so ein Opfer muss ja auch mal gebracht werden, ne. Also irgendein Bauernopfer muss ja gebracht werden.
Ja. Da ist die Frage,
Wie die USA jetzt drauf reagieren? Wahrscheinlich erstmal gar nicht, aber sie haben zumindest mal wieder mal miteinander telefoniert hier nie. Chefs, ne. Ist ja auch schon mal was.
Nach einem Jahr,
Gut und äh unsere Freunde von der NSA.
Ja, da ähm es gibt ja nach wie vor, das war so ein Thema, was wir ähm,
Immer wieder anders beleuchtet haben und wo wir bis jetzt noch keine Klarheit haben, ist, wie findet eigentlich das Abhören am,
Dezix an dem Internet in Frankfurt statt. Es gab da zwischendurch die,
Die Info, die NSA habe dort voll Zugriff, dann stellte sich raus, och schau an der BND hatte auch irgendwie jahrelang Vollzugriff, aber man hat das dann irgendwann wieder eingestellt,
weil das irgendwie politisch zu brisant äh sei, äh da abzuhören. Und irgendwie ist jetzt gerade so die Abhörsituation am Dezex gar nicht klar und
Betreiber des DTX haben dann schon vor Monaten in Interviews gesagt so ja äh,
Uns ist nicht bekannt, dass hier ein Deutscher oder ausländischer Geheimdienst spioniert, aber wenn das so wäre, dürfen wir auch nichts dazu sagen,
Das war so der der die
der Dezix Punkt dazu. Und es gab jetzt nochmal eine Sendung im öffentlich-rechtlichen, die also den Verdacht nahe legte, dass der äh BND weiterhin Zugriff dort auf sämtliche Datenströme habe,
und zwar dank der Hilfe eines großen deutschen Internet Providers, dessen Name aber nicht genannt wird. Ähm.
Mhm. Der am Zix präsent ist. Das ist also nicht das, was man jetzt vielleicht erstmal denken würde, wenn man großer, deutscher Internet-Provider hört.
Ja, nee, das ist nämlich interessant, weil am Six präsent sein, was anderes äh bedeutet, als dort zu pieren und dort präsent ist natürlich auch die Deutsche Telekom, düpiert ja nur irgendwie nicht.
Was macht sie denn sonst? Ich meine dazu ist man auch da.
Das sind äh Fragen, die ähm uns wahrscheinlich nur äh Clemens oder so beantworten kann, aber du kannst dir,
äh
beim äh Dezix auf der Seite halt auch anschauen, wer da alles Kabel hingelegt hat oder beziehungsweise Glas werden die ja dahin legen. Ähm,
Und da gehört auch irgendwie ein Ende der Deutschen Telekom. So, aber es ist irgendwie auch im Bereich der Spekulation zu unterstellen, dass sie das nutzen würden und dass sie da ausgerechnet irgendwie einen Port haben, wo alles drauf geht, ja? Also
schwierig. Also es hat sich da eigentlich nicht viel getan, aber äh zumindest die Information, dass es dort ein ähm,
äh dass das also mit Hilfe eines ähm großen deutschen Internetproviders geschehe scheint es jetzt dann zu geben,
Warte mal, ich suche das mal raus, wo das hier.
Tja, die Telekom.
Deutsche Telekom AG äh ist da mit einem,
mit einer dran. Ja, also sie haben da etwas Anliegen und zwar das, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe.
Dreiunddreißig zwanzig.
Ich verlinke das mal.
Also mit anderen Worten, man weiß jetzt nicht genau, welcher Provider das ist, aber es gibt eine Meldung, dass es irgendein Provider sei, der groß sei.
Ja
Also ich meine, wie viel große Internetprovider gibt es denn in Deutschland, die wirklich über eine eigene Kabelinfrastruktur äh verfügen? Das ist ja jetzt eigentlich nicht so viele.
Ja, ich ähm also was was soll man da jetzt spekulieren? Ist jeder, jeder.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, also mir fällt jetzt auch einfach nicht ein, welches jetzt der zweitgrößte ist.
Also die
ich fand die Frage halt oder ich finde diese Meldung interessanter, weil weil man eben immer noch nicht weiß, wie sie da überhaupt hinkommen, ja? Oder weil's dann eben der der Verdacht auf den
Dezix viel auf die Betreiber und dann ist wieder die Frage, sagen die, was sagen die dazu? Die sagen, wir dürften da aber nicht drüber reden. Na ja, okay, dann weiß, das ist ja auch immer schon mal sehr schön
Wenn jemand sagt, ich darf da nicht drüber reden.
Die zu erwartende Antwort wäre nein und das wüsste ich aber.
Haben wir noch nie gemacht.
Und wenn jemand sagt ist nicht und wenn es so wäre, dürfte ich das nicht sagen, äh dann fragt man sich, wieso düftest du das denn nicht sagen, welcher Vertrag würde dir das denn verbieten, von dem ich nichts weiß? Also.
Naja,
Also total unklar, aber irgendwie äh es klingt jetzt, um das mal so ein bisschen ohne zu viel Humor zu kommentieren,
Das klingt alles so fishi und ich meine, mittlerweile hat, glaube ich, keiner mehr so richtig den Glauben da dran, dass beim Zix nicht Datenströme ausgeleitet werden, wie das so schön heißt und zwar äh im großen äh Maße. Wenn man jetzt mal so,
abseits der äh Bürgenden Nachrichtenlage. Welches Szenario kannst du dir denn da vorstellen?
Äh an welcher Stelle?
Na ja, ich meine, wie ist denn nun ist, weil ich meine, wir hatten ja nun äh so die erste große Frage war, sitzt die NSA auf dem Kabel des Zix, so, ja?
Gut, weiß man nicht, klang aber erstmal nicht so äh wahrscheinlich. Zweite Frage ist, sitzt der BND auf allen Kabeln? Werden alle Daten äh an den BND generell auch weitergeleitet wird, dort alles gedoppelt?
Äh wie ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr so ganz Herde Informationslage, aber so richtig beantwortet ist das auf jeden Fall auch noch nicht. Ja, so. Wenn dem nicht so ist.
Also ich gehe davon aus, dass der BND dranhängt,
auf verschiedenen Wegen. Es wäre ja auch aus der äh Strategie eines Geheimdienstes, der ähm Enthüllungen fürchten muss, gar nicht blöd, dass auf verschiedenen Wegen zu machen und immer nur ein Teil,
Ähm und wie der BND dann damit umgeht und diese Daten eventuell wieder mit anderen Geheimdiensten teilt,
Würde man ja daran ablesen können, wie sich die Bundes äh Regierung gegenüber anderen Ländern, wo diese Geheimdienste eventuell herkommen könnten, verhält.
Und da,
legt sich jetzt meiner aus meiner Perspektive schon die Hypothese nah, dass es einfach genauso ist, wie es offensichtlich ist. Der BN oder wie es offenbar erscheint, der BND hängt dran,
Und äh teilt entweder Ergebnisse, teile oder sonst was mit den Amerikanern und ähm die Herausforderung beim Umgang mit solchen Daten ist ja deren Verarbeitung,
und deren Filterung, das heißt, du kannst nicht einfach das äh also du kannst natürlich
sagen, okay, du schreibst das alles roh weg, dann hast du aber ein Problem, äh das, was du da roh weggeschrieben hast, irgendwann nochmal zu analysieren. Das heißt, ähm, wenn du solche,
Data-Strukturen baust, maust du dir ein ein Gerät, was,
grob vorsortiert und kategorisiert und dir dann durch so verschiedene Abstraktionsebenen ermöglicht, dich in diesen Daten zu zu orientieren, ja, also Grobfilter ähm der.
Es ermöglicht so auf Anhieb,
Diese Art Traffic oder diese IP oder sonstwas zu finden in der Datenbankstruktur und dann noch den letzten Teil, den machst du dann halt wirklich mit Datenstrom, den du durch den Prozessor schaust, äh scheust, ja? Ähm.
Das heißt, du hast einmal so ein, so ein, so ein Schnell äh Analysetool, was grob vorsortiert und ein eventuell dann eben auch Dinge wegwirft, ne? Du brauchst da halt keine äh keinen von YouTube,
Ja, das kannst du,
komprimieren, indem du sagst, dieses Video wurde geschaut, ja? Da brauchst du nicht mehr mit wegzuschreiben, was in dem Video drin war. Ähm dadurch kannst du natürlich schon mal sehr viel,
Datenstrom wegfiltern und Speicherbedarf reduzieren,
und dann eben noch verschiedene Abstraktionen äh dazwischen nehmen eben die die dein Datenbanklayout so machen, dass du bestimmte Creols halt dann am Ende relativ schnell machen kannst.
So und ähm das möchtest du natürlich relativ schnell machen und dann brauchst du halt irgendwo Platz zum speichern.
Und dann reduziert sich natürlich auch das, was du noch ausleiden musst. Ist ja immer dieses schöne Beispiel äh oder dieser dieser Treppenwitz, den man da macht, so der BND darf nur zwanzig Prozent der möglichen Kapazität,
überwachen, ne? Gut, jetzt wird die mögliche Kapazität meistens nicht,
ausgenutzt, sondern man ist ungefähr bei zwanzig Prozent der Gesamtkapazität, also dürfen sie eh alles, aber von dem, was, egal, was sie sich anschauen, ist achtzig Prozent E-Video, was sie nicht speichern müssen.
Ja, klingt auch so ein bisschen so, ja, wir dürfen ja nur zwanzig Prozent überwachen. Jeder, daran hält sich jeder unserer fünf Standorte.
Ja und oder so, ne, also das ist ein völlig abiturer Wert
der der eben auch egal ist und wenn du sagst, äh ich meine E-Mails machen ja am Gesamtverkehr relativ wenig aus, äh was ja auch immer das Argument dann wieder bei diesen Netzneutralität Sachen ist, so ja äh die E-Mail kann noch warten, wenn der Nachbar mal ein HD Video guckt oder so. Also das ist ähm,
Ich gehe davon aus, dass die sich da Sachen teilen und diese Herausforderungen so etwas vernünftig zu bauen und mit so einem Datenstrom umzugehen, die ist eben groß und auch nicht in Kürze gelöst
und deswegen äh scheint ja auch der BND eben Ex-Keescore von den äh US-Amerikanern bekommen zu haben
oder von der NSA bekommen zu haben und das wird er sicherlich nicht bekommen haben, ohne äh
dass er die Möglichkeit einräumt, dass die auch darauf zugreifen können. Also das ist jetzt so meine Hypothese gemischt mit einem kleinen technischen Exkurs.
Okay,
Ja, dann haben wir ja hier noch unsere Kollegen aus Großbritannien so, die sind ja auch immer nicht ganz äh untätig.
Das war schön, ne? Im Schatten, wir haben gar nicht damit gerechnet. Keiner wusste, dass in US äh in in Großbritannien auf einmal der Notstand ausgebrochen ist.
Hat man gar nicht mitbekommen, aber in Großbritannien ist tatsächlich der Notstand ausgebrochen. Sie mussten jetzt sofort einen Notstandsgesetz verabschieden. Ähm weil, und das war jetzt zitiere ich die Innenministerin,
Mörder werden nicht gefasst werden,
Terroristen werden unbemerkt Pläne schmieden können, Drogenschmuggler werden keine Gefahr äh fürchten müssen. Kindesmisshändler, Handler,
werden nicht gestopft werden, Sklaventreiber,
werden ihren Handel mit Menschen weiterführen können und unschuldige Leben,
werden für immer verloren sein, wenn wir dieses Gesetz nicht sofort verabschieden,
Dieses Gesetz hat den schönen Titel Data Retention and Investory Powerspil,
Und damit führt die Vorratsdatenspeicherung eingeführt und noch ein bisschen mehr, denn.
Vergessen noch zu erwähnen, dass Krieg, Frieden ist, äh Freiheitssklaverei und äh Unwissenheit stärke.
Das natürlich. Aber ist es Unwissenheit im Original ist es ignorant, ignorants.
Ja.
Pigments ist. Ähm also wir zitieren natürlich gerade George Orwell Nineeigin so ein Retro futuristisches Buch.
War mal ganz populär. Ja, also das ist halt äh ist ein bisschen,
Es langweilt irgendwie schon so furchtbar immer wieder dieselben äh Argumentationen zu hören, ne, so. Vor allem sieht das ja auch alles Versprechen, die bisher einfach durch eine VDS noch nirgendswo jemals eingelöst werden konnten.
Da äh okay, erinnere mich dran, dass ich gleich nochmal auf was zurückkomme. Ähm also zusätzlich zur Vorzeitenspeicherung möchten sie,
das Recht haben, Überwachungsersuchen an ausländische Unternehmen zu stellen,
ohne dass die Zielperson im Bezug zu Großbritannien steht. Da frage ich mich jetzt
was wie sie mit einem nationalen Gesetz sich das Recht einräumen wollen, woanders im Ausland zu fragen und warum diese dann Folge leisten sollten, aber sie werden sich dazu Gedanken gemacht haben,
Äh sie haben generell irgendwie Abhörvorhaben sowie
die Herausgabe von, also Unterstützung von Abhörvorhaben sowie die Herausgabe von Kommunikationsdaten soll jetzt erstmal so eine die Grundpflicht eines jeden Bürgers werden,
was Kommunikation ist, die Definition soll auch ausgeweitet werden, so dass äh Mailanbieter,
runterfallen. Kurzer Exkurs in dem gleichen Land ist grade ein Student ins Gefängnis gegangen, der sich geweigert hat, äh das Verschlüsselungspasswort zu seinem Computer oder einem Container,
mit verschlüsselten Dateien zur Verfügung zu stellen. Dafür ist er gerade in Beugehaft gegangen sechs Monate.
Hardcore.
Das heißt, du verschlüsselst deine Daten, die Polizei kommt rein, nimmt den Computer mit und sagt, gib Passwort.
Du sagst nö.
Und du sagst nein und dann ist halt äh sechs Monate Beugerhaft. Das ist übel. Das ist äh sehr übel,
Das äh.
Das Gesetz ist ja auch nicht ganz neu, es gibt schon eine Weile, aber,
her sind noch nicht so viele so viele Fälle bekannt geworden, in denen das auch wirklich so zum äh Einsatz kam.
Aber ansonsten doch eine ganz interessante Strategie, so mit dieser Auskunft nach außen. Das wäre doch vielleicht auch was für die Bundesregierung. Sie könnte ja ein Fremdmächte, Auskunftsgesetz erlassen, dass ihnen sozusagen ermächtigt äh bei den USA alle Informationen äh über die Geheimdienste zu bekommen.
Lächerlich, also eine Hälse. Und ich glaube nicht.
Funktionieren, das ist doch ein totaler bürokratischer Hakenschlag, ja.
Das Krasse an diesem äh Data Retention and Investory Powerspil, ist, dass es als Notstandsgesetz,
im Schnellverfahren introduced wurde. Das heißt, die haben das jetzt innerhalb einer Woche eigentlich durchgepeitscht und zwar haben sie es jetzt in mit vierhundertneunundvierzig zu dreiunddreißig Stimmen,
Im Schnellverfahren durch das Unterhaus bekommen. Jetzt steht noch das Oberhaus aus, da müsste sie, glaube ich, jetzt heute oder morgen rein und dann,
morgen und dann könnte es quasi schon am Freitag Gesetz sein. Und die ganze Nummer, die er vergleicht mit einem Blitzkrieg, sei hier,
gemacht? Haben sie haben sie dann halt in in etwas mehr als anderthalb Wochen,
durchgezogen. Und das ist, wenn dieses Beispiel jetzt Schule macht, vermutlich auch das, womit wir in Deutschland rechnen müssen, ähm um ähnliche Arten von Gesetzgebung durchzubringen.
Aber es gab jetzt in den es gab jetzt keinen Vorfall, an dem das Ganze festgemacht wurde. Also.
EuGH-Urteil, VDS und so. Es gab jetzt nichts konkretes. Also ich habe nichts mitbekommen, was jetzt irgendwie ich als konkret bezeichnen würde.
Europa ist vielleicht die Gefahr.
Ich weiß nicht, was der in Gefahr ist. Also sie haben's ist ich weise nur darauf hin, diese Strategie zu sagen, oh äh Notstand. Ähm,
müssen wir sofort durch äh durchziehen. Ey, ich meine, wenn unschuldige Leben in Gefahr sind, dann ist ja wohl Notstand.
Terroristen, Kinder, Kindesmisshandler.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist ja eigentlich der der richtige Begriff. Ja, äh Sklavenhändler, weißt du, wenn die auf einmal deine Insel fluten, dann wirst du doch mal schnell ein kurzes Notfall Notstandsgesetz äh durchziehen können.
Vielleicht ist der neue Kommissionspräsident, den sie fürchten.
Ich ich hebe den, ich hebe warnend den Finger, da müssen wir mit rechnen. Und die Strategie hat ja funktioniert, wenn du dir irgendwie das anschaust, was für ein ähm,
Ergebnis, ja, das ist ja Faktor mehr als äh Faktor sieben zu eins hier, vierhundert äh neunundvierzig zu dreiunddreißig. Das ist ein Fußballwitz gewesen, Tim, hast du gemerkt? Ja, ja.
Ich habe mir gerade den Kommentar verkniffen.
So, ne? Und da haben sie irgendwie ähm so, das heißt, es gab da keine Debatte
Es gab, es hat sich irgendwie der zivile Protest überhaupt nicht erst formieren können und schon stehen die Leute da und gucken doof. Und mir ist die Strategie auch völlig unklar, irgendwie da was zu machen
wo jetzt gerade schon der der EuGH irgendwie den Sack zugezogen hat. Vermutlich denken die sich, ach weißt du was, äh
bis bis da eben die Klage dagegen irgendwann mal beim EuGH landet, äh haben wir mit dem schon gar nichts mehr zu tun.
Aber die Britannien hat doch schon eine VDS. Also ich meine, was ist jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht dann so die eigentliche Verschärfung?
Oder.
Ich muss äh dazu sagen, dass ich dir nicht den vollständigen Status da nennen kann,
Und sie werden sicherlich gemacht haben mit Grund. Also dieses Gesetz wird schon eine Veränderung des Status Quo ähm herbeiführen.
Naja, da bin ich mir auch sicher. Frage ist nur, in welchem Maße. Na gut. Säuft Britannien,
Das ist echt krass. Schon irgendwie echt interessant, dass äh George Over das nun wirklich auch seine Vision ja nun auch explizit für für Britannien formuliert hat.
Hast du da noch was dazu oder wollen wir äh fortschreiten.
Ach so, ich wollte noch äh nenne Pöppe. Also Warnung, dass wir in in anderen Ländern auch aufpassen müssen. Und ähm.
Wolltest noch zu meiner Anmerkung irgendwie.
Ja, ich finde das, ich finde das sehr äh interessant. Ich hatte ein Gespräch äh die Tage mit einem äh Polizisten, Rang, Rang hoher Polizist,
Großer Freund der Vorortsdatenspeicherung. Ähm und der äh wies also daraufhin, ne, dass äh
Kindesmisshandlung und äh dokumentierter Kindesmissbrauch. Natürlich so ein großes Problem ist und somit die Täter sitzen im Ausland. Und ähm da sind ihm natürlich die Hände gebunden, da brauchen wir unbedingt eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Und dann frage ich mich ja, wenn die Täter im Ausland sitzen.
Warum müssen wir denn in Deutschland alle Daten mitspüren.
Und ich möchte die Leute im Inland schützen vor diesen Cyber-Angreifern, dann frage ich mich ja, warum ich dann ausgerechnet im Inland die Leute überwachen muss, ne.
Fand ich ganz interessant. Also, dass jetzt die Argumentationsfee, aber er räumte ein, dass ähm,
es wahrscheinlich gerade seine Forderung nach der Vorratsseitenspeicherung politisch momentan nicht opportun sei?
Und das äh er deshalb auch bereit ist, noch ein paar Monate zu warten.
Ich habe auch so den Eindruck, dass so in Polizeikreisen das auch wirklich so ein Mantra ist mit diesen äh mit der Vorratsdaten,
Also das ist da einfach wirklich so, weil's die äh heilsbringende Universallösung ähm etabliert in den Köpfen. Ich habe das auch schon ein paar Mal bemerkt,
Obwohl es ja, wie es zumindest unsere Sicht ist,
ist einfach nirgendwo, wo es bisher eine gab, irgendein Beleg dafür gibt, dass das, was dort äh beabsichtigt wird, damit auch tatsächlich erreicht wird.
Ja, vollständig also ein ein vollständig äh wirkungsnachweisfreies äh äh Verfahren.
In der tja.
Die hat ja noch andere Sachen erzählt, ne. Also wir die Unterschiede, die es dann so gibt zwischen den Providern. Ja, also nur.
Verhalten oder was?
Ja, also nur, weil du keine Vorzeitenspeicherungsrichtlinie hast, heißt das ja nicht, dass ähm.
Was gespeichert hast.
Dass du die Hardware jetzt wieder abbauen musst,
Nur du bist nicht mehr gezwungen sie zu betreiben. Aber der Drag steht ja jetzt nun mal da. So und willst du jetzt irgendwie jemanden hinstellen, der sagt, ich trage das jetzt alles wieder raus oder sagst sehr gut, da stehen.
Ist ja schon bezahlt. Das hat man nicht abgeschrieben.
Da gibt's also auch Unterschiede. Das ist aber auch dokumentiert, ja. Ich möchte da jetzt nur nicht ihn zitieren. Also die Unterschiede der äh deutschen Anbieter sind äh in der in der Vorhaltezeit sind dokumentiert. Das haben wir auch hier schon mal äh im Detail behandelt. Welche Vorhaltezeiten
ist dafür Einzelverbindung und IP-Adressen gibt. Ich werd die ja haben wir. Das wurde nämlich mal geliefert.
Mhm. Ja, wurde auch woanders.
Genau die Liste der Bundesprüfstelle für jugendgefährdende Medien.
Ja. Ja.
Kennst du die? Ja. Ich kannte die gar nicht, muss ich sagen.
Na, ist das nicht die Prüfstelle überhaupt, die äh quasi die Empfehlung rausgibt, was jugendgefährdet ist und was nicht.
Da sie Bundesprüfstelle heißt, würde ich jetzt mal unterstellen, dass da dass sie das als ihre Aufgabe sieht. Aber ich dachte jetzt äh Andy äh Liste selber, also kanntest du die Liste selber?
Die haben äh eine Liste, wo dreitausend URLs draufstehen,
die sie als jugendgefährdend einstufen.
Also eine Blacklist.
Genau und damit diese Blacklist nicht im Klartextformat vorliegt, haben sie die Domains da drin gehasht. Ja, also da steht nicht ähm.
Da stehen die Logbuch äh Punkt DE, sondern da steht dann drei, sieben, neun, fünf, irgendwas. Mhm.
Sondern da steht dann ein MD fünf oder ein äh also eine eine kryptographische Prüfsumme. Und,
in dieser Liste, also ist jemand hingegangen, eine anonyme Person, hat diese Liste genommen und hat gesagt, okay, ich versuche jetzt mal, herauszufinden, welche Domains das denn sind auf dieser Liste. Und ähm,
bis zur gewissen Zeichenlänge kannst du eigentlich so MD fünf Fashels äh einfach auch so über Onlinedienste knacken lassen oder eben mit
äh überschaubaren Zeitaufwand ähm,
selber knacken wenn's dann irgendwie ein Zeichen zu lang wird, dann gibt's da noch so Online-Dienste, die,
im Prinzip haben, ja?
Oder die dir dann anbieten in so und so viel Stunden diesen äh zu knacken gegen Geld oder.
Ja, vor allem, wenn's nur Domains sind, kann man ja so die populärsten, die man ohnehin vermutet, ja, mal schnell, einfach mal durchhäschen und dann weiß man's ja auch.
Genau und das ist genau der der Ansatz, den äh diese Person dann verfolgt hat,
hat nämlich einfach andere geliebte Sperlisten genommen und hat die schon mal abgefrühstückt und dann blieben halt am Ende nur noch sehr wenige über. Die wurden dann einem äh komplizierteren Verfahren zugeführt, ja, dass man geschaut hat und ähm,
letztendlich hat ähm glaube ich äh drei, also blieben irgendwie so eine handvoll über von diesen dreitausend, ne,
weil man eben verschiedene äh Inputquellen genommen hat. Und diese Liste wurde dann veröffentlicht, ähm auch von äh Netzpolitik Org, ich glaube sogar von Andre Himself,
und dann haben sie relativ schnell Post bekommen, dass das ja äh nicht so gut wäre.
Und ähm dass sie gebeten wurden, dass äh diese diesen Link äh dorthin zu entfernen, weil sie Kinderpornografie damit verbreiten würden,
und jetzt das ist natürlich irgendwie ein Vorwurf, mit dem du dich nicht auseinandersetzen möchtest und äh Heise DE hat
Post auch bekommen. Und äh Netzkritik Org hat er in diesem Link entfernt. Heisa hat ihn entfernt. Chip Online
Thomas Stadler, also eigentlich alle äh haben dann,
diesen,
diesen Link entfernt Udo Vetta hat dann auch nochmal dazu erklärt, dass dass tatsächlich äh rechtlich riskant ist. Ähm,
Und eigentlich, dass ja auch ein Verfahren ist, was am Ende keiner führen möchte. Ja ähm,
Insofern war diese Liste einige Zeit online. Alle haben sie sich runtergeladen und wissen jetzt, dass äh gut die Hälfte der Domains dadrauf überhaupt nicht mehr existiert.
Und dass ich siebenunddreißig Diät-Domans dadrunter äh befinden,
was ich dann auch wieder interessant fand, weil man ja eigentlich erwarten würde, dass diese DE Domain-Betreiber sich nach dem Jugendmedienschutz äh Jugend, Medienschutz Staatsvertrag richten müssen,
Äh und das anscheinend äh nicht getan haben. Ja.
Aber wo kommt denn diese Liste überhaupt zum Einsatz, frage ich mich?
Das fand ich nämlich dann spannend. Da wurde nämlich bei Netzpolitik dann darauf hingewiesen, dass diese Liste Teil einer jeden Fritzboxfirma ist zum Beispiel.
Ach, das ist das, wenn man aha.
Und jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob die das grundsätzlich zensiert oder ob das das ist, was passiert, wenn du denen das Häkchen Jugendschutz anmachst bei der Fritzbox.
Und leider habe ich die Liste jetzt nicht hier, um das mal auszuprobieren bei dir, weil bei mir zu Hause mache ich das nicht.
Ach so, na dann. Ja gut, ich meine,
Fritzbox dann, weißt du, ob die Fritzbox dann sozusagen schon die DNS-Auskunft äh sperrt, also es ist darüber realisiert, dass dann sozusagen Domains gar nicht gesäuft werden. Okay,
Das heißt, wenn man nicht den den.
Wenn man den nicht nutzt, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich das wirst du dir den Effekt des Jugendschutzes nicht haben.
Ich habe solche Sachen natürlich immer ausgeschaltet, deswegen muss ich gerade mal gucken, wo man die überhaupt einschalten kann.
Ich müsste jetzt nochmal die Liste irgendwo herkriegen, was jetzt zunehmend schwierig ist. Gucken.
Sich sicherlich was machen lassen.
Ja, das ist jetzt nicht so schwer. Letztendlich hat sie dann sogar die Person, die sie äh da anonym geliebt hat, ähm offline genommen, aus welchem Grund auch. Also hat sich dann auch der Punkt war halt gemacht, ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen.
Dass ich nicht weiß, also es wurden halt ähm,
es wurde halt einiges auf dieser auf dieser Liste gefunden, was jetzt wahrscheinlich, sage ich mal, übertrieben war, zu blockieren. Aber ähm.
Die dich so übertrieben haben.
Ja, ich habe mir ich habe mir da jetzt wenig angeschaut, es waren dreitausend Domains und das war.
Kennst sie alle schon, die sein.
Das kann auch sein,
Ich weiß es nicht. Also, wie gesagt, die Hälfte davon hat nicht funktioniert. Also das Argumente, die Argumente, die natürlich immer zu solchen äh Listen gemacht werden, sind ähm, dass sie als andererseits halt, wenn sie geliebt werden, als äh Wegweiser dienen können,
heißt, jeder will diese Liste habhaft werden, um äh eine ordentliche ordentliche Sammlung an Domains äh zu finden. Ähm,
und andererseits, dass sie halt zu viel sperren. Ähm dieses Argument ist zu viel Sperrens, fand ich auch jetzt bei dieser Liste,
noch nicht so sehr gegeben wie zum Beispiel bei bei anderen Systemen, die eben zum Einsatz kommen oder die,
äh in anderen europäischen Ländern, wo wir diese Sperrverfügung eben wirklich auf der Providerebene haben, ja? Und wo dann andauernd irgendwelche Open Source Systeme und wat nicht alles auf der Sperrliste landen. Und wo sie jetzt wirklich ausharren und,
gehen. Und da muss ich sagen, ist diese Liste jetzt dann doch eher noch wenigstens in einem Rahmen geblieben, wo man,
äh nach meinem kurzen Überblick,
habe ich da jetzt wenige Beispiele gefunden, wo ich sagen würde, da ist jetzt großer Flurschaden angerichtet, dass ähm.
Dass äh Jugendliche daran gehindert werden, diese vollständig äh jugendfreundliche Seite auch zu sehen. Da gab's einige Beispiele,
die also jetzt nicht jugendgefährdend waren, das gibt's immer. Dieses Argument konnte man machen, aber diese Liste schien jetzt in ihrer Gänze nicht so völlig äh völlig daneben zu sein, wie viele andere, die man dann schon gesehen hat.
Also ich habe jetzt nochmal kurz geguckt, äh mir ist nicht ganz klar, wo, also wenn wenn diese Liste hier irgendwo ist, dann ist sie als solche nirgendwo einschaltbar, also sie müsste sozusagen von sich aus aktiv werden. Ähm weil es,
Also es gibt zwar eine Möglichkeit, Black zu konfigurieren, die sind aber leer. Ähm mir ist nicht so ganz klar,
Aber jetzt gibt's ja noch die, die Kindersicherung, aber die Kindersicherung hat ja auch nur eher was damit zu tun,
Ach nee, da gibt's noch diese Zugangs, ja. Ah ja doch, hier steht's ja. Für Gast, ah ja genau, es sind zwei Listen, nämlich Blacklist Komma, BPJM.
Ah, siehste, da ist sie, ja.
Angegeben. Jetzt habe ich's gefunden, muss hier bei den Tabs irgendwie erstmal durchgehen, aber,
Jugendgefährdende Internetseiten sperren, genau. Das kann man hier,
einschalten für ein bestimmtes Profil, das ist bei Diefold das Profil Gast. Ja, also das, was kommt dann normalerweise nur zum Einsatz, wenn du äh explizit einen Gastzugang öffnest, ja?
Für irgendwelche Leute, die nicht du selber bist. Und die kriegen dann äh dieses,
Modul und das ist hier dann zumindest mal als solches auch äh angezeigt und man ist hier aber auch davon die Rede, dass man die Liste anzeigen kann.
Nee, das ist genau das.
Liste gesperrter Internetseiten ist Lea, heißt es hier.
Ja ja, du kannst halt noch welche draufsetzen, aber du kannst diese BPJM-Liste nicht anzeigen. Also das war ja genau das, wogegen sie sich schützen wollten. Sie wollten halt ähm dafür sorgen, dass sie nicht mit jeder Fritzbox im Prinzip ein Telefonbuch äh
ausliefern.
Na ja klar. Tja, na gut, aber jetzt haben wir das zumindest mal gefunden. War mir das jetzt noch nicht so ganz sicher.
Ich habe die Liste ach so, da dürfte man ja gar nicht zugeben, oder? Also ich glaube, ich hab's irgendwo noch hier rumliegen. Ja, ist jetzt auch egal. Also.
Ja. Du lenkst ja nicht drauf.
Nö, ich lese dir jetzt vor und jeder, der hier drauf link kommt, Knast.
Das war's dann.
Nee.
Habt ihr jetzt davon.
Also ähm,
Punkt gemacht. Ähm schlimm ist es, wenn sowas eben in einer, in einer Infrastruktur zum Einsatz kommt, die dann nicht mehr im in der Hand der Nutzer liegt ähm und dann äh kann da eben, dann wird er natürlich auch da mit betrieben.
Hm? Genau, aber bei der Fritzbox muss gleich noch mal zu sagen, so wie es da jetzt offensichtlich integriert ist, ist es äh nur dann aktiv, wenn man's auch explizit einschaltet.
Was auch in dem Fall, finde ich, richtig ist.
Ja, gibt's da sonst noch was zu hinzuzufügen? Erstmal nicht, oder?
Nee, wir wir bleiben aber bei.
Oh. Ja.
Ähm auch nur eine ganz kurze Meldung, ja? Ähm,
Es gibt den Digital Millennium Copyright Act. Und ähm das sind die äh so bekannten DMCA-Notes.
Man so Webseiten wie YouTube dazu bringt, äh von Dritten hochgeladenes Copyright behaftetes Material schnellstens wieder zu löschen.
Weißt du, womit das übrigens passiert?
Äh womit was genau passiert.
Kommen irgendwelche Fernsehteams bei mir vorbei, wollen irgendeinen Mist von mir hören? Ich bin noch so freundlich, nehm mir die Zeit und erklär den irgendwas, dann nehmen Sie irgendwie 'n einen Satz daraus und dann,
kriege ich eine eine Mitschnitt davon. Stell den auf YouTube und dann kommt das. Dann nehmen die das wieder runter,
Weil ich nicht das Copyright daran habe.
Nee, du hast ja auch so einen Wisch unterschrieben, wo drauf steht, äh ne?
Unterschrieben? Nee.
Sie wollen einem doch immer eins vor die Nase halten.
Ja, das äh können die vergessen. Nee, nee, ich unterschreibe nichts.
Hm. Du Rebell.
Rene ähm also unterschreiben musste, was wenn du so bei längeren äh Sachen mitwirkst, wenn du jetzt irgendwie so als wir äh da im Regierungs Handys abgehört haben, da mussten wir heute unterschreiben, damit wir Geld kriegen. Nee, aber die,
die ähm äh wenn du wenn die so vorbeikommen und irgendwie dir drei Fragen stellen, du kurz deine Antworten gibst, dann äh unterschreibst du da nichts für.
Ähm aber genau Etze ist einer auf die Idee gekommen, hm einen Politiker, der ähm,
Auf einmal feststellte, oh äh meine Doktorarbeit findet sich auf dem ähm.
Schon mal so der ein oder andere politische Größe darüber gestolpert ist.
Genau und.
Worauf bezog sich nochmal Vroni? Wer war das.
Das war, war das nicht die Tochter von Franz Josef Strauß oder sowas?
Kann sein, ja.
Ja genau, Veronika Sass, Edmund Stoibers Tochter.
Edmund Stoiberin. Das ist ja nochmal eine andere andere Hausnummer als Franz Josef Strauß. Der hat hier Franz Josef Strauß hat ja äh der war ja gemeingefährlich. Der war ja auch noch intelligent, der war ja nicht nur blöd, sondern auch noch intelligent. Aber bei Stoiber ist das ja nicht so.
Ja, ja gut. Aber das äh spricht ja nicht unbedingt also gegen seine Tochter, ne. Wer weiß.
So und der aus welchem Grund auch immer ähm also was was passiert ist ähm,
Diese Person namens Doktor Sandro L hat also ihre äh Plockt
plagierte Doktorarbeit auf der Arbeit. Ähm
hat hat sich dann auf dieser Plattform wiedergefunden, hat gemerkt, die äh Plagiat-Sammler äh machen sich ans Werk und hat sich gedacht, naja, Moment, die machen doch da gerade mein äh mein geistiges Eigentum zugänglich und hat sich dann einer DMCA-Notes bedient, um
den Betreiber dieser Plattform, nämlich Vicky Ja dot com dazu zu bringen diese Doktorarbeit offline zu nehmen.
Und dadurch die Plagiat-Sammler an der öffentlichen Untersuchung dieser Arbeit äh zu hindern.
Das ist natürlich äh.
Also Wikia muss man dazu sagen, das ist so diese Wikiplattform, die seinerzeit von dem äh Gründer der Wikipedia äh mitgegründet wurde, äh Jimmy Wales,
weiß nicht, ob er da überhaupt noch seine Finger mit drin hat, aber die natürlich selber auch in den USA äh basiert ist,
Das heißt, sie,
hat eine Vorstellung von DMCA äh Notes, ob jetzt allerdings Copyright Material von außerhalb der USA überhaupt über dieses Gesetz aktiviert werden kann, sei mal dahingestellt, aber äh vermutlich reagieren äh solche Systeme an der Stelle auch schon,
automatisch.
Also das ist jetzt, muss man sich jetzt mal überlegen, was man da äh also wie man das in, also das wird natürlich jetzt Schule machen, ne?
Ja, ist denn das, ja gut, ich meine, dass da, dass da dass da Urheberrecht draufliegt, ist sicherlich nachvollziehbar, so. Aber eine Veröffentlichte Doktorarbeit, ja, keine Ahnung, Urheberrecht.
Also ich würde ja folgendes machen, die Leute sollen sich die Doktorarbeit irgendwo herholen,
Die muss da ja nicht öffentlich sein. Und in dieser in dem Vroni Plug zeichnet man dann nur die plagierten Passagen. Also die Plagiat Funde. Und dann soll der mal sagen, er hätte daran Urheberrecht.
Ja gut, ich meine, dass sowas wie Wiki ja reagiert, das äh ähm.
Dann wollen wir mal sehen. Also nee und dann kannst du hier wenigstens so ein schönes, peinliches Verfahren für die gegen die Person leisten, ne. Also das wäre ähm.
Im Nachgang. Naja gut, aber ist wieder.
In Auszügen darfst du ja. In Auszügen darfst du ja.
Vor allem wenn es eh nicht sein URL-Bericht ist. Also das fände ich halt geil, ne? Das ist aber mein Urheberrecht, so nee ist nicht,
zitieren da ja gar nicht deine Arbeit. Wir sammeln ja nur, wir zitieren ja eine ganz andere Arbeit. Du hast das ja nur auch da rein geschrieben,
Also es ist schon, es ist schon echt geil, ne. Also ich meine, die die Ironie, ja, dass du als Plagiator da irgendwie,
potentieller Plagiator ähm,
Mutmaßlicher Plagiator stehst und äh dich dann mithilfe des Urheberrechts gegen eine Untersuchung wärst, äh in der äh zu die Frage der Frage nachgegangen wird, ob du das Urheberrecht verletzt hast.
Ja, ist schon echt cool. Das ist echt gut.
Das ist schon gut. Das war übrigens ja auch nur.
Sternchen, ne, also.
Eine sehr schöne Meldung ähm äh Slavoy,
der äh slowenische äh Popstar der Philosophie. Ähm ein äh eine großartige Figur, ähm der also sehr unglaublich äh schöne äh schön provokativ sich zu Themen äußert. Ähm,
Kann man nur empfehlen,
dem wurde jetzt auch ärgerlicherweise ein Plagiat nachgewiesen. Ähm und zwar war das zu verständlich. Die Leute sind darüber gestolpert, dass auf einmal eine Passage in seinem Text klar formuliert war und äh haben dann.
Nicht so verschlüsselt wie sonst.
Genau und haben dann herausgefunden, dass da die äh dann zu allem Überfluss äh auch noch von irgendwelchen rechten äh abgeschrieben hat anscheinend. Ähm,
Was sehr ärgerlich ist, weil er eigentlich so einer der der Stars der, der, der, der Linken auch ist, ja. Ja, schade.
Ich hoffe mal, er wird's mit Fassung tragen und dann nicht irgendeinen Tanz aufführen. Wir kommen zu den Klagen. Es gibt drei Klagen, die wir noch behandeln müssen. Tim, dann sind wir durch.
Mhm. Da fangen wir an. Äh hebe die Klage. Also äh die Klage erhoben hat, fragt den Staat und zwar gegen die äh Bundesregierung. Genau. Und da ging's um die Informationsfreiheit.
Wir hatten das Thema behandelt, die hatten dieses ähm.
Ich dachte, das wäre schon längst durch oder ist das schon wieder.
Genau, die haben's nämlich jetzt andersrum gemacht, also ähm frag den Staat,
hat ähm damals äh TM,
Ähm dieses Gutachten der des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes für den Bundestag, das für die Bundesregierung, ich glaube für das Innenministerium angefertigt wurde, ähm,
veröffentlicht und dann wurde ihnen ähm begegnet mit,
Ache. So, dann wurde ihnen begegnet mit ähm einer Abmahnung oder wie oder einstweiliger Verfügung. Bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher.
Ich glaube, da ging's doch auch um Urheberrecht.
Genau und dahaben sie gesagt, wir, das äh Innenministerium mahnen euch ab,
denn wir sind Inhaber des Urheberrechts über diese Stellungnahme über die Prozent Hürde bei Europawahlen. Und ähm,
gegen diese Abmahnung hat, fragt den Staat dann selbst Klage eingereicht
und zwar eine sogenannte negative Feststellungsklage, denn nachdem sie äh gesagt haben, wir werden dieser Abmahnung keine Folge leisten, ist äh nichts passiert,
So und dann haben, gibt's jetzt eine eine gab's eine Reihe von Verfahren, ähm,
wo es dann vor allem, wo sie vor allem Gericht schon Recht bekommen hatten, wo sie das nicht wussten,
Also dieses diese diese Klage wurde irgendwie,
von einem Gericht beantwortet, behandelt, wo sie das irgendwie gar nicht von wussten, dass also auch nochmal strange, aber ähm,
Diese Klage,
oder dieses Urteil hat äh das das Innenministerium äh vollständig anerkannt. Und jetzt hat das Landgericht Berlin ein Anerkenntnisurteil äh gesprochen und das heißt, das ist jetzt quasi ein rechtskräftiges Urteil gibt, dass,
Kein Urheberrecht an solchen Dokumenten gibt.
Okay. Das ist jetzt festgestellt worden. Genau. Mhm.
Beziehungsweise über diesen negativen Weg ist es festgestellt worden, dass es kein, dass man kein Recht damit verletzt, wenn man das so an.
Genau. Und die Anwälte sagen dann, ja, wir halten das trotzdem für richtig, aber wir ziehen das äh unseren Punkt aus Prozessökonomischen, ökonomischen Gründen zurück.
Eigentlich haben wir ja recht, aber das ist jetzt.
Ja, aber wir lassen's jetzt irgendwie lieber wir verlieren lieber, dass die das Verfahren vor Gericht.
Lassen fünfe grade sein.
Nee. Also ähm das ist ein war äh gerichtlich irgendwie bis äh ähm juristisch alles ein bisschen wirr vor allem mit dieser Klage, von der sie nichts wussten. Aber sie haben gewonnen,
Äh herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Ja, sehr schön. Also, frag den Staat, macht sich äh sowieso immer wieder sehr gut und äh hier eine weitere Etappe in einem interessanten Hürdenlauf durch die Behörden clippen,
So, zweite Klage.
Die beiden Berliner Freifungaktivisten Ralf Gärlich und Bianco Feigel, wobei ich mir bei dem Namen diese Freifunkaktivisten, die haben immer Namen, das kann doch gar nicht sein
Also ich glaube ernsthaft, dass sie da
jedes Mal äh ich habe im im Freifunkbereich echt selten mal einen Namen äh gehört, der glaubwürdig ist, außer einmal, wo jemand den Nachnamen Neumann hat, der ist völlig unglaubwürdig ist,
Ähm.
Da würde ich auch irgendwie nix glauben.
Bei denen geht es darum, also Freifunk ist eine,
erweiterte WLAN-Technologie, die bauen also äh Mesh-Netzwerke, das heißt, es ist etwas unterschiedlich zu der klassischen Access-Point-Client-Infrastruktur, äh sodass diese
dass man speziell modifizierte WLAN-Router äh auf die Dächer schnallt, die.
Auch miteinander sprechen und sich dynamisch äh Ruden mitteilen. Das heißt, das Freifunk Netzwerk ist relativ groß und an einigen Stellen in diesem Freifunk-Netzwerk kann man eben auch,
Ist dieses Netzwerk dann auch mit dem Internet verbunden? Ja? Und das heißt als äh als Freifunnker kann man,
Teil dieses Netzes werden, man schnallt sich so ein Ding aufs Dach und hat dann eben Zugang zu dem Freifunk-Netzwerk, wo dann auch allerlei ähm,
interessante Dienste stattfinden, ähm die also lokal in diesem Netzwerk angeboten werden, sowie
Zugang zum Internet durch eben bestimmte Exitpunkte. Und ähm das hat natürlich relativ schnell den Betreibern solcher ähm
Exitpunkte Ärger eingebracht, wenn dann eben anonyme Freifunktion da Dinge getan haben
die in Deutschland drakonisch verfolgt werden, wie zum Beispiel, man hätte jetzt irgendwie was weiß ich, eine MP3 runtergeladen vom Lied oder so,
Ähm dann werden ja die IP-Adressen festgestellt und dann gibt's Briefe und Abmahnungen und so und alles teuer. Und äh das Freifunkprojekt ist irgendwann dazu übergegangen zu sagen, komm.
Wir machen einfach ein großes VPN,
wo wir dann wiederum die ganzen Freifunkexits dran schmeißen, damit wir dann als Internetzugangsanbieter gelten, als ein Großer. Und ähm für den gibt es für Große.
Internetprovider gibt es einen Provider Privileg gemäß Paragraph acht, Absatz eins des Telemediengesetzes,
Das, für die keine Störerhaftung gilt. Und störerhaftung ist ja genau dieses Prinzip, dass man sagt,
ähm von deinem Anschluss wurde das Vergehen begangen.
Also haftest du.
Also haftest du? Wir haben das Thema sehr häufig schon behandelt. Wir haben über die ähm Cafés gesprochen, die hier vor einem Jahr mal in Berlin rebelliert haben. Ähm,
Wir haben, glaube ich, auch über viele Abmahnungen gesprochen, die irgendwelche äh.
Auch über erste Gerichtsurteile, die jetzt die Störerhaftung eingeschränkt haben vor kurzem erst, ein, zwei, drei Sendungen.
Genau und schon noch bevor es Lokbuchnetzpolitik gab, habe ich mit ähm,
Markus Beckedal und Ulf Buhrmeier auf dem neunundzwanzig C drei,
einen Vortrag äh gehalten, in dem Ulf auch darüber gesprochen hat. Und jetzt kommen wir zum Punkt, dass nämlich es ein juristisches Unding ist, dass die,
ähm das für große Provider wie selbstverständlich keine Störerhaftung gilt. Also.
Könnte ja zum Beispiel auch sagen, ja, liebe Telekom, dein Nutzer äh hat hier Böses getan, also seid ihr jetzt schuld? Weil das ja äh im Prinzip technisch gesehen jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel anderes ist, weil die Telekom hat ja aktiv ja, sehr zu sehen, hat sogar Geld dafür genommen,
Ja, äh ja, die verdient sich daran auch noch dumm und dusselig, dass die Leute äh hier äh Raubkopien äh verbreiten. Ja, die müssen alle in den Knast,
Mit derselben Logik macht man halt Kaffees dicht.
Oder eben Menschen, die so freundlich sind, ihre Netze mit an ihren Internetzugang mit anderen Menschen zu teilen. Was in vielen Ländern,
Gang und gäbe es
ja? Äh ich glaube, ich habe auch vor einiger Zeit mal in der Sendung erwähnt, dass ich das auch mache und dann eben auch dazu gezwungen bin, dass durch Tor oder durch einen VPN zu werfen, damit äh
ich da nicht irgendwann äh auf einmal tausend Euro bezahlen muss, weil jemand irgendwie äh falschen Link geklickt hat oder so, ne.
So und das Problem ist eben, was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen einer kleinen,
Person, Einzelperson vielleicht sogar oder einer Hobbyisteninitiative, die Gutes tun will und Menschen Internet bringt,
und einem großen Provider und juristisch gibt es den nicht,
Denn das Gesetz unterscheidet nicht, ob man anderen Menschen Internet zur Verfügung stellt, äh ob jetzt kostenlos,
oder gegen Entgelt oder was auch immer.
Und das ist eine Rechtsunte Sicherheit, die Ulf eben auch schon seit einiger Zeit äh bemängelt. Der hat dann da auch äh damals einen äh Gesetzesentwurf äh formuliert, in dem dann eben,
das das geltende Gesetz nicht geändert wird, nur nochmal,
geklärt wird, was im Gesetz steht. Also er hat das genannt, äh Jura für Domir oder für Jura für Dummies, wo dann also nochmal der gleiche Satz äh,
Anders formuliert nochmal steht, damit sie's auch wirklich verstehen. Und ähm gegen diesen Umstand möchten sich also jetzt diese beiden frei von und sagen, naja,
Wir haben äh offensichtlich hier das äh nicht so betrieben oder wir sehen das auch nicht mehr ein mit diesen ähm VPN und deswegen,
möchten wir uns nach vorne verteidigen und zwar gegen die Störerhaftung klagen.
Das tun sie jetzt. Haben sie jetzt eine negative Feststellungsklage ähm eingereicht beim Berliner Amtsgericht in Neukölln und in Lichtenberg? Frag mich jetzt nicht, warum sie die gewählt haben. Die werden da ihren Grund für haben. Wahrscheinlich weil sie da wohnen.
Ja und das Ganze ist vor zehn Tagen hat das stattgefunden. Siebten am siebten Juli. Ja.
So und jetzt könnte es also echt sein und das wäre natürlich sehr.
So, warte mal, eine Frage habe ich, seit wann gibt's denn diese technische Lösung mit den VPNs, dass die ganzen äh Internet Exit-Notes nochmal gebündelt werden?
Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, seit wann sie das machen kann, aber noch nicht so lange sein.
Ja, das ist mir nämlich total neu. Ist das ein Angebot oder ist das quasi dann für die Community verpflichten.
Das machst du halt als Notbetreiber.
Kann man machen, muss man nicht machen, ja, hm, okay.
Na weiß ja nicht, vielleicht gibt's da ja auch so einen Deal, dass man das einfach getan hat, aber.
Also die ähm.
Ist so ein Thema, glaube ich.
Dahinter ist, dass der der der Verein Freifunk ist ja äh stellenweise durchaus mit Mitteln ausgestattet. Und äh dadurch, dass sie halt ähm Spenden bekommen und dadurch, dass sie ja,
hauptsächlich ihre ähm,
Leistung da absolut äh ehrenamtlich erbringen. Das heißt, ähm also ich habe inzwischen kein Freifunk mehr auf dem Dach, aufgrund baulicher äh,
Umstände, aber ähm das Gerät, mit dem ich das gemacht habe, habe ich ja selber bezahlt,
So, das war ja auch eine Hobbysache, dass sie einfach gesagt hat, möchte ich, finde ich cool, mache ich mit. Und so ist ja dieser gesamte Verein. So und dann kriegen sie auch äh ab und an mal ein bisschen Hardware gespendet, um,
Internet in dunkle Regionen zu bringen und ähm jetzt dann Server zu betreiben zu deinem VPN Exit zu machen und so ist dann jetzt keine äh große Herausforderung. Wenn man,
eben das alles nur mit Freiwilligen und Ehrenamtlichen gestaltet,
Aber es wäre also jetzt wirklich ein ein großer Verdienst und auch sehr toll. Ähm und es ist auch, glaube ich, dieser Verein prädestiniert,
das zu tun und man kann ihn da äh wirklich nur das beste Gelingen wünschen.
Ja, ich denke, das ist ein Thema, was wir auch vielleicht mal nochmal separat ähm aufgreifen äh können und gerade so diese vielfältigen äh rechtlichen Aspekte, die jetzt konkret bei Freifunk da so zum Tragen kommen, das ist ja nicht das einzige
vielleicht auch nochmal so ein bisschen in den Fokus nehmen, wenn wir die Zeit dafür haben. So, last but not least.
Die dritte Klage. Ähm.
Ein einziges Klagelied hier.
Du möchtest noch was äh twittern oder.
Morgen. Ja, was ist denn die dritte Klage?
Ja, okay, Tim, Tim, hantiert schon mit dem iPhone. Ich merke, ich muss zum Ende kommen. Ähm.
Ich äh bin zeitlich äh knapp und muss äh Vorwarnungen austeilen.
Unsere Freunde, äh unsere Podcast-Freunde von Metrolaut, nämlich der John F Nebel und der Hans Gift haben sich vor, ich glaube, zwei Jahren,
äh ins Wendland begeben, um dort äh zu berichten,
mit in Form von Podcasts, haben sich also an den beim Castor-Transport äh mit den dort protestierenden unterhalten und haben,
ähm
Menschen in den Sitzblockaden interviewt, haben Polizisten interviewt und haben für das äh radiofreies Wendland da Beiträge ähm gemacht. Die kann man sich auch natürlich alle noch anhören online. Und ähm,
Sie sind dann in,
Den Konflikt mit der Polizei geraten, die ihren gesamten VW-Bus samt dem ganzen Podcast-Equipment, was sich darin befand, beschlagnahmt hat,
und sie so an der weiteren Ausübung ihrer Tätigkeit gehindert hat. Ähm es war, glaube ich, ein, das hatte also einen Ausfall von mehreren Stunden zufolge, bis neues Podcast-Equipment da war,
und sie mussten sich dann ein anderes Fahrzeug leihen und das ist ja schon durchaus eine nennenswerte Beeinträchtigung der äh journalistischen
Freiheit, die ihn da äh zuteil wurde.
Stellt sich nochmal vor, das wäre während der WM passiert.
Nein, da hätte halt keiner darüber berichtet. Ähm und äh die beiden haben also dann diese ihre Beiträge da äh,
irgendwie noch weiter produzieren können, waren aber natürlich, ob der Behandlung, die ihn da zuteil geworden ist und auch aufgrund der Unterstellungen, die äh da in diesem Beschlagnahme-Bericht getätigt wurden,
Ähm sehr äh unglücklich mit dem, was da geschehen ist und haben sich dann an das Verwaltungsgericht dort gewendet und darauf geklagt, dass bitte festgestellt würde, dass diese,
Beschlagnahme, die da stattgefunden hat, ähm.
Illegal war, ja. Mhm.
Und das äh Urteil wurde dann schon vor, ah, das war irgendwann im Mai, das war Ende Mai, äh wurde dieses dieses äh Urteil schon dann vom vom Verwaltungsgericht gefällt. Aber es kommt ja dann noch die,
ähm Urteilsbegründung. Das war das Verwaltungsgericht Lüneburg Lüne.
Die ist jetzt rausgekommen.
Und die ist vor ein paar Tagen rausgekommen und die ist interessant, weil da drin also erstmal äh,
länglich darauf eingegangen wird, welche unglaubwürdigen Aussagen die Polizisten eben zu dieser zu dieser Beschlagnahme gemacht haben. Sie haben da also unter anderem behauptet, ähm
da wäre irgendwie ein GS äh also irgendwie eine Radiostörsender oder was äh ne, dass er
unmittelbare Gefahrenabwehr. In dem ganzen Auto war keine Antenne, weil VW-Busse die äh Radioanten ins Glas eingelassen haben, ja. Also ähm haben da,
wirklich äh üble Unterstellung gemacht, auch über das äh auch über das Verhalten der beiden. Ähm denen das Equipment da weggenommen wurde.
Noch irgendwas mit dem Beschlagnahmungsprotokoll, die nicht vollständig waren.
Genau, das standen da war die waren einerseits nicht vollständig und andererseits äh standen da halt Dinge drin, die es nicht gab. Ja, also irgendwie Radio. Wir beschlagnahmen hiermit UKW Störsender,
ja. Hättest du natürlich auch also äh Hans und John haben dann äh sich sofort dagegen beschwert äh darüber beschwert und die ähm der Rechtsbestand, der quasi in ihrer Nähe stand, da ist ja auch immer alles voll von von ähm wie heißen die denn?
Erfahrungen läuten.
Ja, aber im,
im Wendland heißt das noch mal anders. Da da gibt's dann mal quasi einen eigenen äh eigene Gruppe. Ähm da waren also auch Anwälte dabei, die ähm,
dann quasi mit waren. Also bezeugten, was dort geschah. Und äh ich hätte ja eigentlich lieber gesagt, okay, den Radio Störsender,
den schreib mal schön das Protokoll und dann klag ich dich, verklage ich dich 'ne Woche später darauf mir mein Radiosender wiederzugeben.
Ah ja, wo ist denn der? Hier steht jetzt noch schwarz auf weiß. Ja.
Wo ist denn der? Weiß. Ja. Ja.
Mein kleines Atomkraftwerk hier,
Schreiben sie auf, MacBook Pro mit Retina Display.
Sechzehn Gekram.
Also nein, sie haben sich natürlich dann und das war wahrscheinlich auch das Richtige, äh sofort dagegen gewehrt gegen diese äh falschen,
Artikel, so aber kommen wir mal langsam zum Punkt. Also, lange Zeit und viele äh Verfahren äh viel Wartezeit später ähm wurde dieses Gerichtsurteil ähm,
gesprochen, dass ihnen in allen Punkten Recht gegeben hat und auch die äh widersprüchlichen Aussagen der Polizei dann da äh genüsslich seziert und vor allem sagt,
ähm die Geräte, die äh ähm,
Die Geräte haben diese Menschen gebraucht und es war unabhängig davon, eine Verletzung der Pressefreiheit,
Selbst wenn die Menschen nicht im Besitz eines Presseausweises sind,
Und das ist ja äh das war jetzt nicht überraschend. Das war auch Teil der Argumentation der Kläger in diesem Fall. Das Pressefreiheit nicht daran gebunden ist, dass du neunzig Euro für einen Presseausweis im Jahr an irgendeinen,
Verband. Äh überweist der dir dann im Gegenzug diesen Presseausweis gibt.
Man ist quasi Presse. In dem Moment, wo man nachweisen kann, dass man presseähnliche Tätigkeiten äh durchführt.
Dass man äh journalistische Tätigkeit nachgeht und das war eben hier ganz offensichtlich der Fall. Während keinerlei äh Gefahr,
unmittelbar von ihnen ausging und wenn die Polizei meint, die hätten da ein Kernkraftwerk in dem Bus gehabt, dann hätten sie einen äh Technikexperten zurate ziehen müssen,
Und die Argumentation der Polizei war eben, ja, unmittelbare Gefahrenabwehr, wir hatten gar keine Zeit mehr, da ein Technikexperten zurate zu ziehen, weil wir mussten ja äh,
verhindern, dass die,
Terror ausführen. Wenn man sich diese Podcastreihe äh aus dem äh vom Castor mal der Reihe nach anhört, dann bekommt man auch so einen groben Eindruck,
an welcher Stelle,
Sieht dann eben diese Reaktion bekommen haben. Also ich will das das ist natürlich jetzt Spekulation, aber die Folge, bevor sie dann, bevor ihnen dann das Equipment weggenommen wurde, da interviewt er äh Hans Gift ähm,
relativ harsch einen Polizisten und stellt diesen Polizisten recht äh unangenehme Fragen auf die
dieser Polizist keine Antworten weiß. Und äh wie wir wissen, wenn Menschen keine Antworten wissen, dann äh neigen sie zu äh Gewalt und Ungerechtigkeit und das ist eben da geschehen. Und das wurde jetzt auch festgestellt. Und das ist äh
denke ich sehr schön, auch für uns als Podcaster, weil wir jetzt sagen können, dass wir Presse sind und Journalisten.
Weil wir presserähnliche Tätigkeiten durchführen. Es gab ja auch eine ähnliche Debatte mit den äh Bloggern, die nicht in den Bundestag äh hereingelassen werden, weil sie keinen Presseausweis haben,
Da ist zwar wohl auch glaube ich schon wieder zurückgerudert worden, aber jetzt hätte man im Prinzip sogar ein Urteil, äh wo man da auch klar argumentieren kann im Zweifelsfall
Ist natürlich, woran kann man jetzt sozusagen Presse erkennen, ja, wer was ist denn jetzt sozusagen der Maßstab, äh schreit das jetzt nach einer weiteren Regelung äh oder lässt man das per se offen, soweit ich weiß, ist ja auch explizit der Beruf des Journalisten nicht geschützt, damit man ihm genau eine solche
Ausschluss äh Klausel auch überhaupt gar nicht erst heranführen kann, um zu verhindern, dass jemand journalistisch tätig wird. Ähm insofern ja,
man ja auch sagen wir mal äh auch mal mit innerhalb anderer Organisationen Presseausweise äh herausgeben können, die halt andere,
Kriterien haben als die, die jetzt die üblichen Journalistenverbände haben. Also jetzt ohne äh großen Hintergedanken wäre äh durchaus mal ähm zu überlegen.
Das Gericht schreibt in der Begründung der Schutzbereich war unabhängig davon eröffnet, ob die Kläger Inhaber eines Presseausweises waren oder nicht, Presseausweise werden, anders als beispielsweise Rechtsanwaltsausweise, nicht
von einer öffentlichen Stelle, sondern vom deutschen Journalistenverband ausgegeben. Voraussetzung für den Erhalt ist die
berufliche Tätigkeit als Journalist, die aber gerade nicht Bedingungen für einen Schutz nach äh Artikel fünf Absatz eins Grundgesetz ist
Der Schutzbereich umfasst nicht nur die Berichterstattung selbst, sondern auch alle wesentmäßig damit zusammenhängenden Tätigkeiten, insbesondere auch die Beschaffung der zu berichtenden Informationen. Durch die Streitgegenstände
Stellung wurden die Möglichkeiten der Informationsbeschaffung und Verarbeitung der Kläger erheblich eingeschränkt.
Super. Dann würde ich sagen, war mal ans Ende gekommen hier unserer tollen Sendung Linus.
Ja, wir müssen noch Metrolaut empfehlen. Die die gehen immer dahin, wo es wo es weh tut, wann auch in Istanbul. Ich glaube, ich hatte davon erzählt. Kann man äh, kann man mal hören, ist sehr, sehr unterhaltsame Unterhaltung.
Genau, die Links, wie alle anderen Links findet ihr in den und äh ja, weitere Anregungen findet ihr in zukünftigen Ausgaben dieser presserähnlichen äh Produktion.
Nebenberuflich.
Ja? Das war doch jetzt Docbuch Netzpolitik, oder?
Ich muss jetzt mal echt noch meine Oma anrufen. Ich glaube, die hat heute Geburtstag.